myth we're having a special speaker
today for the beginning of the year
especially for the new students but
everyone can probably benefit from this
dr. Shoshana zeisman perreo manages OHS
use student academic support services
she has 18 years experience working in
higher education and is passionate about
helping learners achieve their academic
goals she is available to meet with
students to help them with active
learning strategies test taking
strategies learning styles time
management and adjusting to OHS use
learning environment which as we know
can be pretty intense additionally she
supports students and learners by
advocating for them and working with
faculty to ensure that the learning
environment is supportive inclusive and
welcoming for all learners
hi and I do manage student academic
support services here on campus and
today is really about setting yourself
up for academic success so could I just
see a show of hands how many of you are
all relatively new to OHSU so starting
okay so almost everybody great then my
audience is correct for this
presentation Oh before I actually it
really started I am gonna actually pass
around a couple of sign-in sheet because
we like data right and it's important
for us to know who's here
we won't spam you I mean I can't
guarantee that I mean I'm pretty sure we
won't so please feel free
all right where's my okay so objective
so in this talk I want to talk about
different learning strategies I want to
identify at least one active learning
strategy that you can incorporate
throughout your program and I want to
share some advice that I have received
from your upper classmates so anything
that's in purple is something that I
have actually heard from your upper
upper classmates so it might be
something I would have said already
something that I will echo but something
that has specifically been shared with
me so look out for the purple and then
establish essential resources on campus
to help you succeed I will also tell you
that I've already sent this presentation
that today in in PDF form because there
are actually some hyperlinks in here
that have some really great resources so
you don't need to feverishly be taking
notes or writing down any of some of the
different websites so I'm going to point
out because hopefully you'll be able to
get a copy of this presentation later
all right are we there yet
it's day four for some of y'all does
this feel familiar yet have you seen
this have you heard of this like
drinking from the fire hose metaphor I
see yes yes yes all right how are we
feeling right now if you could describe
how you're feeling in one word about
school about your program um tell me
what what are some words you you would
use to describe how you're feeling
I'm just excited okay a classes start
classes started right yeah okay so we're
sighted
busy busy excited sleepy okay yes happy
great any other words curious
does anyone looked ahead in your syllabi
like any of the assignments to come any
feelings on on that dressed okay
okay well mostly all very positive
emotions sometimes when we start really
big programs we feel anxious we feel
concerned about handling the amount of
information that might be thrown at us
and hopefully through some of the
resources we're gonna talk about today
some of the active learning strategies
and tips we're gonna give you some ideas
for handling the flow of information
that's gonna come at you because
sometimes it's gonna feel really
manageable and sometimes it's gonna feel
like you are literally drinking from a
firehose and that's okay but you need to
make sure that you have some coping
strategies so how many of you have heard
of learning styles preferences okay so
um literature on learning styles
preferences tells us well well you tell
me do you think they matter okay
yeah so how so oftentimes we take
learning styles preferences and maybe
some of us haven't even ever taken a
learning style preference or we think we
are we mean towards a different learning
styles and we often don't maybe see
beyond that so we're just going to take
about five minutes right now and do a
quick learning styles inventory and then
I will give you further instructions
after you do that so please we've got
the right way take a few minutes to fill
this out
oh you know I mean
all right I think I can tell most of
y'all are done any surprises oh yeah I
like lots of audience participation you
have any surprises no no no no surprises
at all okay so a couple of things do
learning styles really matter so yes and
no right so for one it is helpful to
have a go to write a way in which we
like to take in information and make it
our own it doesn't mean that's the only
language we can learn information it
doesn't mean that if we don't
particularly like a lecture style
environment that we can't learn from
lecture but it's about thinking about
how we can take information in so that
we can provide the foundation and the
scaffolding to learn new information
right and so what I think is even more
important than just the way in which we
enjoy learning is the second handout I
gave you so it breaks down the four
different learning modalities which this
particular learning inventory breaks
down visual a little bit differently
than other inventories I've seen so you
have visual graphic and visual text so
some other inventories will just do
visual which for me I like the way they
break this out because when I think when
I say are you a visual learner some
people will say yes right and for me
specifically who I am like I am NOT a
visual graphic learner but I'm actually
a visual text learner so I actually like
words but images like if you were to
draw a mind map like I would look at
that and it just looks like gobbledygook
in my brain I can't do it it does not
work so the way in which this particular
inventory breaks out visual graphic and
visual text is really helpful but I
think even more than that what I like is
this third column that I
created which are active studying tips
so again maybe how many of you are
kinesthetic learners okay so what do you
do when you're stuck in a lecture class
does that mean you can't learn 300
things at the same time oh I think it's
at 303 so if you were to look at that
right-hand column there are some tips in
there for things you can think about
doing so our kinesthetic learners might
think about okay I need to maybe stand
up in the back of the classroom right or
maybe if I am someone who needs to spend
many hours doing a task like studying
maybe I need have an exercise ball which
I can sit on so I can keep my body in
motion and my mind can stay focused so
really take a look later not right now
but later at that right hand column and
see if there are any active studying
tips that you haven't thought of that
really do dial in to your learning
styles preference that allow you to be
actively engaged while you're learning
because that is really the takeaway I
want you to walk away with it's that you
can have a go to learning styles
preference but it has to be something
that you're actively doing we don't want
to be passively engaged in the learning
process we need to be actively engaged
does anyone have any questions about any
of that so on the screen we see two
different images this and this what's
the difference between these two
pictures this picture on the left and
the picture on the right if anyone has
anyone ever had a book that looks like
this what are we doing in this picture
on the left your speed reading
oh you're tracking your place
anyone else has anyone ever done this
with like a journal article or a chapter
in a book okay
what happens after we've highlighted
everything nothing's violated right so
now it is all distinct and potentially
either everything that we thought was
important now everything just blends
into each other right so what's
happening to this picture on our right
well I would just take another step back
and say really think about the times in
our educational lives and our histories
where we've done that where we've
highlighted and highlighted and
highlighted and everything ends up being
highlighted and we have we try to go
back and have we processed anything so I
just encourage you to think about again
are we actively engaged in the material
and so the difference really to me when
I look at these two things that this
person over here is really trying to
consolidate information make their own
categories and synthesize the
information from whatever resources
they're using so whether it is from
lecture or from a book or from
powerpoints multiple resources and make
it their own so they have categorized
they have used colors so someone that
might be very visual they've used colors
they have drawn which is great but again
they have made it their own yes they
made their own notes yes
well with that more work yet typically
it does yeah typically it takes more
work for us to retain the information
yes all right so if we could form some
little groups like a rat so groups of
like four I'm just um if you could share
in your groups how is it that you
approach studying new material and then
we're gonna share a back out so I'll
give you just a couple of minutes to
talk about if you were walking into a
class and they were giving you new
information how is it that you approach
studying new information of any variety
so you could form groups
all right so we're going to come back
together as a large group who wants to
share first a strategy that you talked
about in your group who wants to what
group might want to share something like
I'll talk about in your group yes so one
of the things that came up and we were
discussing is the real one of the issues
is that you have this heterogeneity of
learning styles and it's not so much
that there's like a one cut solution
people often have a blend of different
advantages and things and you know even
these nice cute little bins here often
there's a lot of overlap between them
and so one of the things that came up
with us as a potential way to overcome
that is leveraging the use of more
social study groups which can have the
kind of their own kind of structure
evolved organically to kind of conform
to the particular heterogeneity of the
individual members that comprise that
group in terms of allowing dissemination
of information I also think reciprocal
peer teaching so being able to teach
each other one of the things about study
groups they hear all the time from
learners is you know I don't like
studying groups because I'm not often
ready to study when the study group is
ready shaking I'm not ready on Thursdays
when everyone else is ready I need more
time with the material I would argue
that I I see that but sometimes you know
if you go in there should be goals when
you do study groups right like you
should go to walk into a study group and
there should be a couple of ideas and
objectives going in number one you walk
in so that you walk out saying okay I've
checked these things off the list like I
really know these things so I don't need
a solo study those but I still don't
understand these three topics and I need
to go back home by myself or wherever
and study these so
you have some objectives going in and
you also have some ground rules right
because sometimes if we have our friends
and our study groups they tend to like
turn into social circles so making sure
that you know you really have some
ground rules and then again objectives
we're walking in and out of those study
group sessions with but typically that
ability to teach each other or even
depending on the structure of whether
it's a weekly exam or a midterm or a
final if you assign different parts of
the content to each person in your study
group then that is also another way in
which you can divide and conquer the
material what are some other suggestions
that you came up with in your groups
sure so you have an example of sure sir
and on-the-job training right so you're
learning while doing other suggestions
that y'all came up with yes well we were
just talking about at least I don't have
the ability to sit the chair and study
for long periods of time it's better for
me to set a timer and say okay I'm gonna
study this for the next 25 minutes 30
minutes whatever it is and then I'm
gonna take a break I'm gonna come back
so my husband on unlike my husband who
could sit in a chair for six hours and
study I can't do that I I need to have
just defined bits of time with little
breaks yeah and I think I'll touch on
that in just a minute about sort of our
personality types in terms of our time
management and then how we can fit for
very long interview there's some other
suggestions what do you all do in terms
the dip what is the difference between
studying something that's conceptual
versus maybe something that's rote
memory and these suggestions I heard of
something over here
and I'll use color coding like
color-coded highlighters so that I can
recall it visually go back when I need
it
alright so we have writing it over and
over and over get anyone use flashcards
for memorization the flashcards are like
an electronic version of a flashcard
what about our conceptual learning like
so big-picture conceptual what are some
suggestions oh sorry
yes and not and I would argue that very
rarely is it typically just rote memory
right like you often have to take some
thought process to figure out is this
actually just rote memory or is there
conceptual piece for us that we have to
think through yes memory tasks will try
and come up with mnemonics I for one
find that mnemonics from other people
are incredibly unhelpful it is I'm just
having to remember your stupid role of
it you came up with it's more work than
memorizing the thing for as you know my
own are like incredibly idiosyncratic
and pointless and like oh this both you
know starts with the same letter or
others dopey kind of things but if you
think of your own it's a lot more
helpful mnemonics memory palaces
that know-it-all so are you space
prepetition right so if you have to
memorize or even conceptually learn
something you know doing it the night
before an exam isn't gonna work
as well as thinking about Oh two weeks
before my exam how can I break this up
and go over it multiple times before I
have my exam it's gonna be much more
helpful so in terms of active learning
or studying you know again it's about
being actively engaged in the material
because it is so easy to sit and study
okay it is not easy it is it it's easy
to make it very passive right so we sit
we open our book passive we can have
that illusion of studying how many times
have you had your laptop open your book
open you might even just be recreating
powerpoints does that ever happen to you
we're just like nope never a couple
hours go by and you're like what have I
been doing right it's that illusion of
studying you feel like you're putting
the work in but nothing's really
sticking in the brain because we're not
actively engaged in the material so some
tips it's important especially if we're
working with conceptual things so take a
step back and find the big picture what
is it that I need to really how do I
connect the dots and see the big picture
creating summary charts of the needed
information can be really helpful and I
understand that y'all are all taking
different types of classes and so some
of these tips will not work for certain
things and certain classes that you're
doing but when you can summary charts
can be really helpful because imagine
you can create a chart and I am not even
going to attempt to give you a chart
that would apply to your particular
field but if you can create a chart of
the information it's gonna condense what
could be pages and pages and pages of
notes into one page right where you can
compare and contrast that information
where you can visually see for us visual
learners and even our linear visual text
learners you can see that information on
one page versus multiple pages
but you want to actively learn the
charts you want to ask yourself why is
this particular piece of information
related to the next piece of information
how might they test me on this
information can I create questions and
then answer them
so again actively engaged in the process
actively engaged with the information
practice again applying information
through questioning but what's even more
important than all of that and
especially for all of the new students
is asking yourself consistently and
constantly what's working what's not
working
am I actively engaged am i learning the
material or I just shoving it in my
brain and taking a test and losing it
because I think we have all done that
before in our past educational lives and
so it's really important to make sure
that we're retaining the information so
we have to have a reflective piece of
this process all right so now a couple
of additional learning tools sq4r have
any of you heard of this couple so this
is actually something that I remember
being taught this when I was in
elementary school and what's not and I
don't know that it's actually taught
here in Oregon I did not grow up here
but sq4r is an active reading technique
I won't go too much into it but it is
you can google it but it's the S stands
for scan Q is question and then the four
R's are read relate with site and review
and the idea is is that again reading by
nature is very passive right we open up
a magazine or a beach or just read it
very passive so sq4r is a process that
allows us to make reading and active
activity so you can take anything that
you're reading whether it's PowerPoint
slides a journal article a chapter in a
textbook and make it active first thing
you do scan it how is it set up how is
it organized are there pictures look at
the charts and then create questions and
so if for example if you're looking at
PowerPoint slides that your lecturer
might be providing you
do they have learning objectives turn
those learning objectives into questions
so that when you then start going
through the PowerPoint slides the idea
is that you turn you're trying to answer
the questions that you've created so the
question the cue and asking for are
almost the most important piece in this
because the idea is that when you sit
down to read something it's not always
about reading from the first word to the
last word but mostly about thinking
about reading with intention your
reading to answer questions so either
your reading to answer the learning
objective so like a treasure hunt or
learning objectives are great if they
are available to you or you can turn the
headings in a chapter or textbook into
questions and again being really
intentional about that I would also
argue that pre-work especially for those
of you that are in classes whether it's
online or in person and really being
prepared thinking back to any class
where you've walked in and you have some
sense of familiarity of what's to come
you're gonna get more out of that class
than if you walk in cold so I would
argue thirty minutes to an hour per hour
of lecture so whatever that looks like
depending on your classes I recommend
that you do that again that also depends
on your instructor and what they're
providing you with and what's available
in Sakai and can you do the pre-work
that is really between you and your
instructors again reciprocal clear
teaching can you teach it back to
somebody else do you understand it
charts diagrams pictures mind maps and
reflection and self-assessment so again
it's not just about am i studying
correctly and is it am i retaining the
information but also taking the time and
going back over your exams so those of
you that are in courses where you have
exams looking at them and really being
critical and saying okay am I missing
questions because it's a Content deficit
or am I missing questions because I miss
reading them or I'm not taking enough
time on my test or I'm having an issue
with test anxiety but really going back
over them and not just saying oh I got a
85
I'm okay with that really taking the
time if they do a secure review or
release the exams and really being
critical of what's missing here why did
I miss 15% of this exam and trying to
figure out that missing piece okay I
can't I gotta read my notes because so
this is again something for all of the
new learners in the room so again
everything in purple and you will be
able to get this
I think email to you so these are really
good helpful tips so straight from the
upper your upper classmates so learn
statistics and programming so you can
analyze your data efficiently and plot
your results and so they gave me some
suggestions to send you so go to those
sites get used to writing and having to
explain your work to others so this came
through loud and clear when I asked for
advice from your upper classmates also
finding scientists and you admire and
keeping up with their work through their
blogs publications and/or presentations
using Twitter for keeping up with
science and then there's a couple of
Twitter accounts they suggested that you
follow also figuring out a system for a
bibliography and knowledge management
keep a personal PhD notebook so that you
can continually go back and reread notes
and then there is a an article there for
you to read why that is important and
then this is a PDF even though it's an
it hyperlink but it you can go there
once we send this out that is how to be
a successful PhD student so there's a
ton of resources here that you will want
to comb through later for those of you
that are all men okay but I will let you
do that I don't know
so before I get into the why we're gonna
do this I just want you to sort of sit
with a partner
and I want to talk I want you to just
take a minute and go over some two
strategies of reducing stress during the
week yes two strategies
okay I'm glad we like talking about
reducing stress okay so in a moment you
will see that some of the advice that
your upper classmates shared was having
some ways in which you could alleviate
stress during your program and so
another reason why it's important to
think about ways in which you can create
balance is because when we're stressed
and anxious is often the times where
learners tend to just kind of bury their
heads in the sand and say just keep
studying them they keep studying and
that is like big red flags like nope you
need to take a break so I want to hear
from you what are some of the
suggestions that you're gonna do during
the week to sort of just try to
incorporate some balance into your lives
hopefully this doesn't cost feedback
this time so one of the things that came
up is on having essentially effectively
a plan so scheduling out your weeks but
not so scheduling in terms of what you
need to do for work but actually
figuring out okay
where can I kind of squeeze in work so
that way I can fit it around my life and
have other things I'm doing that you
know naturally just by doing them kind
of you know keep your stress levels and
your and your sanity intact like having
hobbies that have some component of
something that happens at a particular
time at a particular place with other
people is very helpful so if I have a
dance coach that expects me to be at the
studio at a certain time then I will do
it whereas some of them like I don't
draw and paint as much as I used to
because it always gets put off so having
that kind of external control and set
time to do something fun is helpful wine
mark
for example
doing something that you didn't actually
think about
yeah
great thank you so also shared that I'm
sure as many of you know is that when
we're stressed and anxious and then also
trying to study that our brains are only
taking in about 15 percent of what they
normally do so we're not but we're again
not absorbing as much as we normally
would so when we're really stressed out
but we still like try to power through
we're just not as effective as we
normally are so it is really important
that we take the time to have some
semblance of balance even during the
busiest parts of your program when
you're up against deadlines that you do
figure out a way in which you can have
some balance so some suggestions some
some suggestions remember for both upper
classmates
I would also echo this is reducing
structions planning ahead and using your
strengths so thinking about how do you
meal plan get sleep exercise plan your
week so thinking about how you fit all
of that in to your week when you do
finally sit down if you are in your
phase of your program when you're taking
coursework versus doing research or even
doing research thinking about reducing
distractions so if your distraction
happens to be your phone you might want
to have that not right in front of you
while you're trying to study or social
media and I would also argue that where
and when you study is as important as
how and what you are studying so I will
tell you that when I was writing my
dissertation I could not write at my
house by it it was before I had a kid
but I will tell you I wanted to sweep my
house more than I wanted to right nobody
wants to sweep
I don't think except that is what I
wanted to do so I couldn't write at my
house I just couldn't do it and so you
have to think about where is the most
effective place for you to study and
when is it most effective for you to
study so for those of you that are gonna
try to squeeze in a few hours of
studying after a fully packed day
you have to decide you know are you as
effective
you know from 8 to 11 p.m. or could you
somehow shift your schedule a little bit
and get up a little bit earlier and
maybe put in 2 hours and be more
effective than trying to do some
studying at night when you might be more
tired time is somewhat fluid and so you
might want to be thinking about that
so are these two pictures here sort of
this hummingbird and these dying
batteries they strongly believe that
there are two essentially different
types of people out there so we have our
hummingbirds I am a self-professed
hummingbird and I just go go go go go
until I cannot go anymore and then I
just like pass out
so um this is why you will find me on my
couch at 8:30 at night every night and
this has always been the case from
either when I was young and before
having a kid and then your people that
need to recharge their batteries
throughout the day they take breaks and
they keep going so really think about
that as you're scheduling out your time
and scheduling out when you're gonna
study and get your work in are you
somebody that needs to take a break
after a long day and then you can hit
the books or use someone that you take a
break you're just not gonna get back up
and start working again so be really
honest with yourself because I know for
me if I worked all day and had class and
then went home I would not start
studying at a p.m. it like would not
happen but for many of you that might be
okay to take the break you might need
the break so self management is key I
call the idea of time management self
management because again we all have the
same amount of time in our day day hours
in our week and so I encourage you to
create a master calendar and I'll pass
out this handout in just a minute
and on that calendar I again would
suggest like an electronic calendar
Google Calendar and put it all of your
fixed commitments so all of your class
time anything that you know is already
happening so any appointments with your
advisers any lab time
and if you're working your work schedule
and then you can see any holes in your
schedule where you will want to schedule
out things like studying you also want
to set time to protect time for
exercising meal planning family time and
most importantly you want to make sure
you have our set aside for studying how
many of you are taking mostly online
courses a few I will tell you that I
think one of the things that our
learners who take online courses really
struggle with is how much time should I
be spending in the online environment
versus when I take classes in person and
so I will just say there's only a few of
you you know if you're taking a four
credit class you know you need to make
sure you're setting aside the same
amount of time to spend in the online
environment that you would if you were
taking an in-person class um I also
encourage you to think about your weeks
beginning and ending on Fridays because
for many of you the largest chunk of
time you're gonna have to yourself is
the weekend so when you walk out of
wherever on Friday look ahead look at
your calendar see what's coming up do
you have any exams you have any papers
that are due do you have anything big
the next week and do you have to
reallocate some of that weekend or more
of that weekend to studying and getting
things done and then commitment creates
method so this is one of my favorite
quotes if you commit to doing something
and setting that intention you will get
figure out a way to fit it all in and
then this goes back to creating school
life balance and I say sort of because I
think at different parts of your program
you're gonna feel like you're more in
balance and then sometimes you're gonna
feel like wow everything I'm doing is
really about school but it's really
important that you don't ignore your
social networks you take time for you
and again that your upper classmates
really wanted to share that it's
important to take time for yourself have
hobbies and a social life because
graduate school is hard and
there's some highs and some lows make
friends lean on each other
mostly communicate with your partners so
for those of you that have families and
partners when you need to take time for
yourself to do bull work they need to
know so communication piece is really
important and then manage expectation so
I think that's expectations of yourself
what you're capable of and also being
realistic with how much time it takes to
do things and lastly this is a list of
resources that you have available to you
to help you through this whole entire
process so I'm available you have your
career development specialist Virginia
your academic advisor Diane you have
your course directors you have jbt who
is healthier to help support you both if
you get sick they also have a counseling
center marked wellness if you just need
to go exercise is go for a swim office
of student access if you're somebody
that has had accommodations in the past
or you feel like that sounds like
something that you might need to inquire
about just have each other but most
importantly I encourage you to think
about you're using yourself I think
students forget that they have a voice
in this whole entire process advocate
for yourself there's something that you
need you need to speak up you need to
talk to anyone on this list
and say one of my needs is not being met
and advocate for yourself I think lots
of times our learners forget that their
voice should be one of the loudest so
that we can help you be successful so
main takeaway is active studying please
do not be passive learn statistics work
on your writing find mentors reach out
there multiple resources to help you and
take time for yourself
this balance is really key as you
approach this somewhat long journey that
is graduate school alright any questions
but I have to hand out two more handouts
I have the time management handout which
just talks a little bit more about
calendaring and then a quick evaluation
just because it helps me knee and again
data